hey here's a really odd story we've
learned that in addition to the Secret
Service protecting Donald Trump Trump is
going to be keeping a private security
force and a private intelligence service
while he's president this is completely
unprecedented not to be confused with
unprecedented which is a totally
different word from earlier this week uh
I thought Trump's intelligence team was
Alex Jones and Infowars I'm shocked that
he's actually going to have something
beyond that but the real concern is that
the Secret Service is basically the most
sophisticated security team in the world
when they're not hiring Colombian
prostitutes which was a really horrible
horrible thing from the from the past of
the Secret Service they're actually
really really good at what they do in
terms of protecting the prepared the
president but Trump has this squad of
loyal ex cops that he wants to keep
around and before we get into the
implications think of the logistical
issues Trump's private security hasn't
been trained in the way that the Secret
Service has and additionally this is the
type of thing that can create issues
between security forces something
sometimes called as too many cooks in
the kitchen and Trump has this guy Keith
Schiller who's been like his bodyguard
for 16 years and there was a major
problem remember when that we we played
the video Trump was at a rally during
the campaign and there was a kerfuffle
right in the front row and it seemed
like maybe someone was going to attack
Trump and Secret Service people jumped
up on stage and then Trump's private
security guy Keith Schiller jumped up on
stage and in the analysis that was done
after the fact there were basically two
major concerns with Trump's private
security getting involved one is that
Keith Schiller is 58 years old and
people said you know he got up on stage
really slowly 58 is beyond the mandatory
retirement age for these guys when
they're actually in the Secret Service
so number one is he really qualified to
be doing this job number two though
Keith Schiller hopped up on the stage in
the path that would have blocked the
exit route if Secret Service determined
that they had to really get Trump out
because it was a threat on his life
Trump's private security guy approached
Trump blocking the exit path that Secret
Service would have used
get Trump off the stage now I'm not
super super concerned with Trump being
exposed to danger that's not my primary
concern here but it's just an example of
how Trump has these ideas and they are
the exact opposite of what would
actually be best to do yeah I can see
how he's getting paranoid and that's
leading him to make these mistakes where
you have Secret Service and his own
private security yeah I'm kind of
conflicting against each other at the
end of the campaign there was also uh an
audience of people and one of the people
yelled gun oh yeah it turns out that the
so-called assassin which is wielding a
sign yeah any who is a trump supporter
also wasn't he I think he may have been
the the the elusive black Trump
supporter if I recall correctly the
other might be wrong about that uh side
note the guy running Trump's private
security team is as I mentioned a former
cop named Keith Schiller total
conspiracy theorists check out some of
the ideas that trumps head of private
security
Keith Schiller believes number one he
believes that 20 percent of Clinton's
campaign cash came from people who were
responsible for the 9/11 attacks Trump's
head of security number two keith
Shiller believes that a grand jury had
been convened to investigate Hillary
Clinton's use of a private email server
that wasn't true and number three a
Keith Schiller
believed that President Obama was
encouraging undocumented immigrants to
vote illegally isn't that wild guys
everybody associated with Trump is
off-the-wall bonkers even Trump security
people are conspiracy theorists
you really are assembling a team of true
deplorable
if you can't even avoid the conspiracy
theorists among the people paid to
protect you what's fascinating too is
Trump's actually poised to make money
off the Secret Service because his kids
will have their protection and be able
to use the Trump airplane right so all
of those costs will be undisclosed to
Congress and and you know they'll be
paying the person that runs the plane
which is Trump so the money will circle
back to him yet that that's not just
with the plane I mean there we've also
talked about how a lot of administration
and security uh people are renting space
in Trump's buildings in order to be
close to Trump
and that money is going back to trumps
company but when you tell any Trumpets
about these concerns they go guys come
on Donald Trump the person is different
than Donald Trump the company the
money's going to Donald Trump's company
it's really really not a big deal this
is all asking for trouble and at the
core of it we know what's at the core of
this Rachel which is that Secret Service
is there to protect Trump Trump's goon
squad is there to be really aggressive
with protesters and that's something
Secret Service does not get involved in
in Trump - if you're gonna have security
in your Trump you want them beating up
on the protesters as well and that's
gonna be one of their main priorities it
is but with Schiller Trump confers with
him on almost all of his decisions oh
yeah I feel like that's it that's a
large wrinkle security stuff and
intelligence stuff Trump goes to a 58
year old conspiracy theorist security
guard that's who is Trump is getting
advice from with regard to security and
uh at and and intelligence you can't
write this stuff uh you you truly can't
write the stuff get ready for the
oppression of uh protesters
constitutionally protected protesters
discuss this with us on reddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com
slash TDP s I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses well the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than
thirty seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at 90
five dollars that's what mine cost and
for every pair of glasses sold Warby
Parker distributes a pair of glasses to
someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com slash TDP s it costs nothing